- I'm lucky enough to get the day off
on this national holiday.
What better way to
spend this beautiful day
than with my favorite girl?
(brisk energetic music)
Essentials.
Water bottle, water bottle,
water bottle, water bottle.
Tennis ball, snacks,
poop bags, sunglasses.
Also, gotta throw in Roxy's Whistle three
to keep her healthy and safe,
but more on that later.
(brisk energetic music)
What's up boss?
(background music drowns out other sounds)
- Yeah
(brisk energetic music)
Nice to meet you
- Hey
- Mike, nice to meet you
(brisk energetic music)
(Whistle three beeps)
So I just got an alert
from the Whistle three app
that Roxy left her safe zone,
and this is a pre-determined safe zone
that the app allows you to set
for Roxy to have an
extra layer of security.
(brisk energetic music)
I'm gonna go and get a
cup of coffee, all right
so you hang out here, all right?
I'll be right back.
Stay.
(brisk upbeat music)
Good job.
Let's go.
Are you ready?
It's dog park time.
Welcome.
(steady uplifting music)
Hi.
Ew, no, you just licked pee.
Are you crazy?
(steady uplifting music)
Go get it.
Bring it, bring it, bring it, bring it.
Good girl.
(steady uplifting music)
Think about all the benefits there are
for Roxy to run around.
Reducing the risk of obesity,
reducing the risk of all
these chronic diseases.
Roxy,
(kissing gesture)
Anxieties drastically reduce
when she's running around
like this.
If you have a dog that's
tearing stuff up at home,
you have a dog that's always barking,
maybe your dog just
needs a little exercise,
and it's a little anxious,
cause it has too much energy.
Oh, get the dog, get the dog, get the dog.
(steady uplifting music)
So, I'm just checking
my Whistle three app,
and it basically acts
as an activity tracker,
to tell me if Roxy has gotten
enough exercise for the day.
It's pretty awesome.
(steady uplifting music)
(woman shrieks)
Roxy...
Hi.
- Hi doll!
- Hi, nice to meet you.
- Marianna.
- Marianna, this is Roxy.
- I have a dog, a little dog.
- Oh yeah?
- It's Charlie, it's Charlie,
Oh oh oh
(woman speaking Italian)
(Mike laughs)
(upbeat techno music)
- A lot of New Yorkers
don't come to Times Square
because they think
there's too many tourists,
there's too much foot traffic,
but personally, this is my
favorite part of the city.
I don't live too far away,
but I always like to come through here,
and really get a sense of
what's going on in the world.
Roxy likes it here.
She gets a lot of exposure
of
food, people,
so it really helps her calm down
and ease her anxiety when
there's a lot of things going on.
This is what makes New York City special.
The fact that we have all
these different cultures,
all these different people,
coming all together in one area.
Laura, we can't see you,
but we're trying to say hi to you.
- Hi
(upbeat techno music)
- [Man On Street] Hey
John, look over there.
(steady calming music)
I love taking Roxy on car rides,
but man,
her hair, the shedding,
if I have the windows open,
Ugh.
I'm not even joking, it's in my mouth.
(upbeat invigorating music)
We're gonna take Roxy to Staten Island,
her home town.
(upbeat invigorating music)
Trailing our car probably
looks so strange.
This is like hair
flooding out the windows.
(upbeat invigorating music)
That is the eastern seaboard
of the United States.
So, if you go that way, you'll hit Europe.
Hello France!
Hello UK!
State Island is also referred to
as the forgotten borough.
But I went to high school here.
So this ain't no forgotten borough for me!
Staten Island.
Welcome to another
beautiful New York City park
Rox, come on,
let's go explore.
(steady stimulating music)
We have our guide.
What's cool about Roxy is,
the SI trained her off leash,
but that's a command to come back.
She actually will go ahead of us,
see the trail,
and then not go forward,
and literally turn around
and wait for us to catch up.
(steady stimulating music)
You wouldn't think this is in the middle
of Staten Island like this.
By the way, this is 10 miles.
All right, so we're in the middle
of this beautiful dense forest,
with little Roxy monster.
What happens if Roxy runs away?
What if a deer comes out,
and she starts running
and I can't stop her?
Well guess what,
I have that little gadget around her neck,
the Whistle three,
that allows me to start
this feature on my phone
called Track Roxy.
The feature is called Track
whatever your dog's name is.
The GPS satellite connects
to the little gadget
around her neck,
and gives me updates on
the map where Roxy is.
And when it does that,
I can get Roxy back.
Roxy, come on.
Come on puppy.
Good girl.
What a good girl.
Good Girl.
(painful sigh)
I got a splinter.
(Mike screams)
That would have been a dangerous blooper.
Rox, leave.
Roxy!
Get outta there.
Ew!
Look what's on her face.
She dug her face into the rabbit hole.
Ew!
We've conquered Deere
Park in Staten Island,
Aw, shake.
Good girl.
Dude, I don't even have paper towels.
What do you with no paper towels
and a dirty dog?
Come on, come on.
I think Roxy was such a
great little pup today,
that she deserves a treat.
She likes these, these empty ones.
All right, Roxy,
you have to pick between
the fox, the rabbit,
and the duck.
Which one of these do you want?
Do you want the duck?
(hedgehog grunts)
Want a chicken?
Rox, get the chicken.
Nope.
Roxy, any toy you want.
Get anything you want.
(stuffed animal squeaks)
You like this one?
Oh yeah, you were thinking about this one.
Roxy, catch.
We have a winner.
(squeaking noise)
Good girl.
Let's go get you this toy.
Last thing we're gonna
do before we go home,
is I'm gonna surprise my dad,
and we're gonna stop by the house.
He doesn't know that Roxy's coming,
but I'm gonna get him to come outside.
Roxy's gonna sprint at him
like a maniac.
Let's watch.
Roxy, who is that?
Go, go, go, go, go, go!
Go, go, go, go!
She's too happy to be home.
Come on in.
My childhood home.
Welcome, welcome kids.
Dad.
(Mike mumbles)
(kissing on cheek)
(Mike's dad mumbles)
(Mike mumbles)
Say hi to the YouTube community.
- Hi!
- Hi YouTube community, say it.
- Hi YouTube community!
- He's so cute.
All right guys,
this is my childhood picture.
Don't judge me.
Look at that guy.
Look at that champ right there.
That's me and my sister.
(upbeat happy music)
Love you.
Bye.
- Bye bye, behave.
(upbeat happy music)
Just got back from our trip
all across New York City,
with little Roxy monster.
I can actually see of of Roxy's activity.
It's pretty cool.
She really walks all
across New York City today.
Huge shout out to Whistle
for sponsoring this video
and partnering with me and Roxy.
If you like the little gadget
that's around her neck,
the link is down in the description box.
Use code Roxy to get 25% off.
And I hope you learned something,
about dogs, about New York City,
about your own health.
And you enjoyed spending with day
with me and Roxy.
(lip popping)
(lip kissing)
(TV scrambles)
Down.
(TV Scrambles)
What better way to
(Mike laughs)
Roxy, what are you doing?
What are you doing, huh?
Speak.
(Roxy speaks)
(TV scrambles)
(lively upbeat music)